so last year I spent three months at the
record Center in New York which is this
magical place where you can go and do
wherever you think is going to make you
better at programming so while i was
there i spent most of my time learning
about natural language processing and
python and i did that working on a pet
project based on Shakespeare's body of
work so what I'm going to do today I'm
going to tell you the story of how I
came up with the approach and basically
it's my journey through learning about
NLP and text classification natural
language processing is the study of the
interaction between natural and
artificial languages where natural
languages are the ones that we use
commonly in every day in communication
between humans and they're the result of
evolution through time and usage on the
opposite artificial languages or those
that are constructive for some specific
purpose so we're talking language
programming languages or mathematical
symbols so in this broader sense NOP is
really includes really every kind of
manipulation that we do with a computer
of know of human languages and recently
with the development of machine learning
it's used to solve a lot of everyday
problems so I've lived in the
Netherlands for only two months and I
speak no Dutch so much in translators
for example are my best friends
literally and spam filters are another
good example of tasks that we perform
every day and with for which we use NLP
every day so I'm starting to I'm
learning about what these cool things
that NLP does and they're all very
useful but I'm interested in whether I
can use it to do something more similar
to what I used to do in high school when
I had to do literature analysis and so I
come up with this question which is can
I use it to identify different generous
in literature so is are the words in the
document is going to tell me the
difference between say comedies and
tragedies so what I do is I find this
text file which includes
all the plays written by Shakespeare
which is not a very big set as he only
wrote a teen comedies and 10 tragedies
and it but it does have a lot of words
it's a very vast dictionary it's about
eleven thousand words so you can already
see the tree problems I have one is I
have a limited set I only have 28 place
to work on the other one is I have a ton
of features to work on if i consider
words my features so because i'm
learning and I'll pee I don't really
know how to go about this and I it's as
much it was much a trial and an error
process I tried if I looked at different
things I looked at a supervised approach
to look at unsupervised approached and a
lot of the standard tools that are using
NLP and I end up coming up with a
two-stage approach that was unsupervised
basically so the first thing i did as i
met as i said was looking in to
supervise document classification this
is because the way I phrased the the
problem is I want to know the difference
between comedies and tragedies and so
this sounds very much like a
classification problem the way you
normally do this is you take a training
set you have a bunch of documents as
input and they are all labeled so you
already know what they are and you do
some feature extraction so you find some
clever way of summarizing the
information in the text and then you
take the features and put it into a
machine learning algorithm and what you
get is a classifier so when you want to
predict a new document you take you take
it an input you perform the same
operations you've done before have some
features pass it to the classifier and
then the classifier will give you a
label the problem with this approach is
that you need a large training set you
need to tell the algorithm what this
labels are what were the characteristics
that of the labels and so you you do
need
a large training set but I also need to
sit down and literally label manually
all these documents if you don't have
them already labeled which is time
consuming now with the Shakespeare
approach which a Shakespeare example I
didn't really have this problem because
I already know which ones are which even
though there are some controversy
whether some of them are actually
comedies tragedies and I done so yeah I
have a limited training set and it's not
really enough to train a classifier it's
too small so I have to move on and I
start looking into unsupervised approach
so this time I don't need a label I can
take the input do is still some feature
extraction find some clever way of
representing the information and then
I'll use this feature to form some
groups and if I've done a good job at
the end I could watch I could look at
subsets of the groups and decide to
leave how to label them so the key point
it's always feature extraction so how do
I take all this information and
represent it in some smart way and not
just smart also it needs to be a simple
data type because algorithms don't
really do well with long text long
strings long sentences they do well with
numbers and simple boolean or other
simple representations of the data so
again I don't know what to do I just
some I asked the internet basically and
ancient says tf-idf is pretty commonly
used to do this kind of task so the
intuition behind tf-idf is if I want to
know if I want to compare documents and
I want to do that using the frequency of
the words I can't just use the frequency
of the term in the document i also need
something that it's going to tell this
is going to capture what that means in
terms of the corporates and so this is
where inverse document frequency comes
in it gives me a measure of how common
is the word in the entire corpus so to
make an example let's assume that we
have love and Juliet and we want to
compare them in
the context of Romeo and Juliet and
we're looking at the shakespeare corpus
and what i assume that they have the
same frequency of 100 and we'll use the
log of the ratio between the number of
documents we have in the corpus and the
number of documents that actually use
this word so you see that did the main
the only difference really in this two
formulas is that what appears lava peels
25 in 25 out of 28 plays and Juliet
appeals is only one so the final score
for the two words it's very different so
love is used because it's used in most
of the of the place doesn't really tell
me much about display Juliet on the
other hand is uncommon relatively
uncommon it's actually only used in
Romeo and Juliet and so the score is
much much higher and if I was only using
this two words to compare the entire the
place Juliet would tell me actually a
lot more than then love unfortunately I
don't have two words I have 11,000 and
so my problem with this kind of do with
these features is that I I have its way
too many I have 11,000 features and even
if I do score them cleverly in ucf IDF i
still have way too many compared to the
28th place that um there are in my
training set and so I need to find a
better way of representing the
information and this is where topic
modeling comes in play a topic is a
probability distribution over a
collection of words so we'll have a
dictionary across the entire corpus and
depending on the on the topical so on
the theme they will have a different
probability of being selected so we have
n documents and capable distribution k
is a number that we set ourselves and
it's a little tricky that is no Golden
Rule two
actually set the parameter but this
means that i can set it to whatever I
want so I can set it to a number that is
small enough to deal with my training
set what lda does is it creates a if it
finds the relationship between the
observed frequency of the words and the
latent variables there are the topics
and so it creates this generative
describes the generative model which
this works more or less like this for
each document you'll select a number of
words that you want to include in a
document then you'll draw distribution
of topics so how given your cake topics
how likely they are of appearing in in
this document and then you look through
even all the words in the document and
you first draw a specific topic and then
draw a word from the conditional
probability of the words in the topic
that this sounds kind of complicated at
least it did sound to me but in reality
is not that bad so let's make an example
to make it clear so let's assume that we
want to create a document of five words
and we want to follow the probabilistic
procedure described by lda what we would
do is we would decide for example that
is composed fifty percent by a topic
about cute animals and then fifty
percent about food so what we do at this
point we already have the number of
words and we know that the permeability
are the topic it's 5050 so we draw the
first topic which is food and we drop
broccoli and then we do that again I'm
gonna do that we draw the topic cute
animals and we draw a panda and then we
keep doing that until we have exhausted
all the words that we want to put in
documents and we get this bag of words
so we don't care about the the order
this is what lda does it just describes
how the words are have been assigned to
a specific document why is this
interesting well it's interesting
because the outlaw looks a little bit
like this what i get is i get a
distribution of words in each topic so
this is what our topic looks like
effectively
I have a dictionary of some hundred
words and probability over here and so
for each topic I will have a different
probability Association associated to
each word which is basically how likely
I am yeah how likely I am to use it in
the document in this topic the other
thing is interesting and it's actually
more interesting for what I want to do
is that I can describe the documents as
a mixture of topics so this represents
the probability of these topics of this
for topics to be to appear in document
one and so darker squares are higher
probability of the topic and lighter
squares represent lighter colors
represent lower probabilities so this is
the first stage of the analysis in in
this candy hxp example so i need to i
want to represent each play like a
mixture of topics this allows me to
reduce the number of dimensions quite a
bit the second stage is a simple k-means
clustering so again I want to find
comedies and tragedies but I want kind
of want data to do it itself I don't
really want to tell because it's an
unsupervised approach I'm not telling
the data work would you algorithm where
to look for it Sookie means creates a
partition of the data into K groups and
it does so minimizing the variability
within clusters and maximizing the
variability between clusters what that
means is that each point Oh each point
is associated to the nearest centroid
which is nothing else than the average
so let's go back for a second to
Shakespeare and the find what we're
looking for comedies and tragedies have
the obvious difference that comedies
have happy endings and tragedies don't
but they also have some differences in
theme and style so for example tragedies
are always a story of a noble hero
with some tragic flaw and dis inevitably
leads him to some sort to a tragic fall
he is often pushed to the fall towards
the full by some supernatural element
think the ghost in Hamlet or yeah so
there's some sort of a natural element
and inevitably the hero dies the
comedies are a little more complex they
tend to have complex plots they have to
put a lot of plot twists and they they
generally have a prominent theme of love
and they also have a very creative use
of the language it's a check speed uses
a lot of puns and creative insults so
this is how it makes it funny so this is
what we're looking for now before I go
through this who's familiar with the NOP
pipeline so like who's actually done all
this stuff so you know how to prepare
the text and stuff right so you guys
might want to like switch your brains
off for a second while I explain what
you do before Jamie analysis because
it's actually not very inspiring it's
just a little boring but you do need to
take the text which in my case looked
like this so it was pretty ugly and you
need to make it much seen friendly so in
some in a form of that machine can take
and process easily the first step is
recognizing the text so eliminating all
this numbers name of the play name of
the cartridge speaking all these blanks
all the descriptions of the screen of
the same all the description of the
characters we don't really care about
this once we've done that we want to
make sure that the the words that have
the same route are represented the same
way which means if we have flowers and
flower we want them to be flower not
just we just chopped off the pleura for
example then we have to delete the stop
words the sub words are all the words
that don't really tell you anything
about the content of the of the plate
and these are things like pronouns and
the verb to be there have their reviews
largely in in in English but they're not
really telling you anything about the
meaning so the trigger point here was
finding a dictionary a list of stop
words that would apply to Shakespeare's
language because he wrote about 400
years ago something like that so the
English is obviously evolved and NLT k
does provide a lot of nice tools for
doing all of these things but it doesn't
provide you old english stop words so
that was a little bit annoying i had to
go and find out how the spelling changed
and these sort of things but anyways
done that I finally have a vector
representation of the text and I can't
run the analysis now I'm not showing any
to any any code because it's really done
with basic functions and it's not it's
pretty boring it's not very inspiring
but I do want to share the results
because they're pretty cool so this is a
representation of the topics in the
document on this side we have all the
plays so each line is actually a
representation a mixture of topics in
the play darker colors are again higher
probability lighter colors lower
probability what you can see and what's
look a little bit suspicious here is
there's at least two topics topic eight
and topic to that are fairly dark and
fairly consistent across every document
so i don't really like this result and
i'm a little suspicious what i want to
do i want to go and look at the actual
distribution of the words in this topics
to figure out why they're so likely to
appear in every document i'm also going
to look at topic one four and five
because those are the ones that seem to
have more variability and so I want to
know what they look like I'm just
curious so topic number two this is the
distribution of the top ten words so the
ten words are most likely to appear in
this topic and I'm going to try and name
the give a name to the topic based on
this so
good would make no give like they're all
very common words in English now we need
to keep in mind that a play is a fairly
long piece of literature so it goes for
what a couple of hours so there's a lot
of taxes what I'm talking it's pretty
common language at least it was common
language at a time and so it makes sense
that this words appear so often in the
conversation so these are common words
the next topic it's got a nice death and
dead in the same in in the top 10 it
also has fear I feel pretty confident
calling it death topic for love is by
far the most likely to have pure I was
hot man lady faith sweet so I'm gonna
say that this is al off topic and
finally sir Lord Hunter gentlemen great
so I'm gonna hold this the hero topic so
at this point I'm pretty happy and yes
common words is in really great result I
don't really want it I don't didn't
really want the topics who represent
that but i did say before I had to make
a compromise because I couldn't look for
a lot more than the top the number of
topics that I used already because
otherwise I I would still have the same
problem so yeah I'm not very happy about
the common words but i do have death i
have loved it i have here and I've just
said these are the characteristics and
themes that distinguish comedies and
tragedies so this point I'm pretty
confident I'm starting to feel confident
that I might be on to something I might
be on the right track so i do that i run
the k-means and i split on two groups
because i'm looking at i'm still looking
for comedies and tragedies and this is
the average of the probabilities across
groups so not surprised topic 2 and
topic eight are pretty much the same on
average across groups and i can see a
significant difference in here in love
and in death and some other difference
in other topics but
seems like the difference is driven by
hero yet to hear a lot and death so
what's really left is looking at which
place went into which group now I have
in green the comedies and in blue the
tragedies group 0 it looks it's entirely
comedies except for Romeo and Juliet I
can live with that after a rommie angela
is like the epitome of the love stories
I can't forgive and algorithm for not
catching the difference between the fact
that they both died and it's not very
happy however group the second group
looks like it's evenly split between
comedies and tragedies and I don't
really have a justification for this so
I'm pretty sad and frustrated this until
I decide to look at something else like
I still want to try and explain this
plate this two ways plate and I'm I
started to look at the dates the place
where performed for the first time so
the y-axis is the ear the play was
performed for the first time and from
the look of it I can tell that there's
an overlapping somewhere here I don't
you the points but there's about five or
six points here so if I was to exploit
three and three something like that
there's an outlier over here but it's
not liar and I'm not really worried
about what it looks like is there's a
some temporal displayed between the
groups so I asked the internet again and
the internet says the experts think that
towards the end of Elizabeth the first
ring Shakespeare started maturing as an
artist and so I checked when Elizabeth
the first died and it's Oh 1603 right
there so it looks like the model is
actually telling me that there's a
difference in style between these two
groups and that the difference lies in
the fact that you over here Shakespeare
is younger he is writing for Elizabeth
the first and he's more influenced by
the classics but most of all he's ready
for his about the first so she probably
has some
specific taste and he meets to please
her because that's what artists used to
do that's how you get you got by at the
time and so later on he matures in it he
devil devil upstairs more mature style
and he's also writing for a new king and
so he changes and I had this like
interesting conversation with a friend
last night and she's she started
literature and so she has a little more
insight on Shakespeare she has a thing
for Shakespeare and apparently this
group the second group so basically he
stopped writing comedies and he started
writing tragic comedies and if you have
a little bit of knowledge about
Shakespeare which i have i have a very
little knowledge which exit by the way
but i do know that some of them are
pretty dark humor so this is a split i'm
pretty happy with it seems like it
worked some way so wrapping up I so my
original goal was finding comedies and
tragedies and so that didn't happen so I
can't use NLP to find a difference in
generals at least not in this case but I
would still use as I could still use NLP
to find some kind of meaningful split of
of the place and it was just not the
thing that I was looking for so what I
learned from this is them so I hear a
lot about using data to tell stories and
I think what I learned from this
specific example was you don't really
need to necessarily to enforce the story
to the data but sometimes you need to
just tell the date led the data tell
their own story and what I mean by that
is I only started finding this like cool
inside about something that I didn't
know when I stopped trying to use common
approach and follow guidelines from
books & tutorials and the sort of things
and when I stopped doing that and I
focus more on what I had and what the
data was trying to tell that's when I
got actually got some insight so that's
the end of it the code is available on
my
github its doesn't notebook with or a
bunch of things that I've done again
it's not very complex code but if you're
interested in the libraries that are
used and the things that are how I got
to the results deaths there um questions
hi thanks to the talk it was great um I
was just wondering if you had considered
a way of dealing with your documents
that would make you have more of them i
mean plays are quite large and they have
yeah a bunch of sort of semantically
meaningful subdivisions so did you give
any thought to I don't know doing sort
of scene by scene classification for
instance or something like this I
thought about that but I actually
haven't done it yet it's one of the
things that I think Abby would be
interesting to see or it probably
wouldn't I don't know whether they would
show a difference in generous or
something else I think in my actually
eventually show like so some sort of
climax maybe in in this story so how the
story evolved through through the play
but Dad it's definitely interesting hi
given that you were able to find this
deviation between i dinnae okay sorry i
well i was wondering if you could if you
try to maybe divide the documents of the
literature in terms of time first and
then if you want to do a literary
analysis perhaps psych ahead perhaps try
that I mean then you can figure out what
was his style in terms of distinguishing
between comedy and tragedy pre 1605 very
well then Elizabeth died and post her
debt yes so you're saying splitting the
analysis into dividing so divided into
subgroups and then do the analysis first
on one group and then the other it
potentially could be done but
that point I would have a very very
small training set so I would be working
on a very on what maybe 15 12 plays
which is not ideal so I still have a lot
of tons of information and I have to
compress it somehow and I'm not sure I'm
not sure how that would come up yeah
yeah thanks for the talk and maybe a
stupid question but what is the benefit
of it i mean if you have one author yeah
and with 18 books and so then you
already have issues but what happens if
you try to generalize it and to several
authors and different times and stuff
like this and then you can predict
anything well right I probably didn't
make it clear after the beginning this
was not meant to be useful to anyone it
was just my own fun and I was just like
learning about NLP and manipulate how to
manipulate text and it was just it was
an exercise more than trying to predict
something if I were trying to predict
the difference in general I would
probably do it with a larger set and
make sure that there's enough
variability between authors
aside the TF blah blah blah the first
thing and then let the individual a
modeling did you also try any other like
board to vector whatever fancy fancy
algorithm um the first attempts that I
did where at clustering because I
stopped looking at the supervisors
approach and I moved into the
unsupervised and the first thing I did
was trying k-means which was pretty
silly because the vectors were way too
long and then I tried the spherical key
means but the vectors were so long
compared to the training set that it was
just not possible and so I had to
necessarily try and reduce the the
dimensions and that's how I got to all
da and then from el día I just kind of
it kind of happened so no fancy stuff I
think if you just have a lot of time to
waste on a pet project I think you will
have a tons of fun to try it's like
basically doing sentence by sentence or
paragraph by paragraph and I think I
don't like the latest version of gin
seem as a very nice implementation of
that yeah I think it's gonna be fun yep
more questions ok so let's thank Serena
again
you